A good founder has to have
has to have a lot of dedication
and enough of flexibility
to be able to reinvent itself.
For me, this is the difference
between the companies that are successful
and companies that are going nowhere.
Levy Raiz, thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
Thank you.
Thanks for making this happen.
It wasn't easy, I know.
It wasn't easy,
but I'm so glad that we made this happen
with all the difficulties in the scheduling.
And I believe that you mentioned
after one of our mishaps email,
if it's really difficult,
it means that it's really, really good.
So, I'm going with that mindset into this.
Levy, let's talk about investments
these 20 minutes.
And you've had the privilege of sitting
on numerous positions
with venture capital funds.
And you've seen countless entrepreneurs.
And I'd love to sort of pick your brain
from your experiences
on some of the key insights that you've gained,
whether it's about
the type of person you like to invest in,
or how does the whole pipeline
look in your mind,
or what entrepreneurs should be doing
as they're approaching the fundraising.
So, Levy, I'll let you take it from here.
Tell me maybe a little bit about yourself
and where you come from.
Okay. Let's start with that.
So, in a few words about myself.
I'm in VC for the last eight years.
Before that, I've been doing
building companies myself.
I had four companies so far.
I know one of them actually succeeded
and I sold it.
The second one is also a success.
It still exists and working and making money.
And the two other ones I just miserably failed.
So, that was why so I kind of learned.
In what order, by the way?
What was the order of them?
Yeah, it was success.
It was the failure.
Second, kind of success,
and then the failure.
I like that. I like the zigzag.
So, I always say it's better to fail fast
rather than drag it out for years.
So, that's my professional career.
And eight years ago,
I've been privileged to be invited
to join one of the VCs
to become a partner in the CPC.
We've invested a lot of companies
here in Israel and I've been privileged
to do some great investments
and some really bad investments.
And now this days with the Digital Horizon VC,
we are an early stage firm.
I'm a venture partner dealing with
all the deal flow in Israel.
And I'm thirty four,
married to another beautiful entrepreneur.
We have three kids who are also probably
look like they're very different home.
That's me. That's me.
What differentiates between
the good investments that you've made
and the bad investments?
The really good ones and the really bad ones.
Is there some pattern recognition
that you now understand,
looking back at the few that succeeded
and the few that didn't succeed?
Yeah, I think I can find some.
You know, there are a lot of factors
that are kind of objective.
And sometimes it's great team,
great technology and there is some just
objective factor.
The market timing is wrong
or there is something out there
that is not dependent on us,
which doesn't work.
That happens all the time
and that's normal.
Now, that's why we're investing to it.
That's why it's called venture capital
we take risk.
With the other cases
where it's more of a people's issue.
I would say that the dedication of founders
mixed with the flexibility
of their kind of mindset is that what I found
as a crucial, crucial things.
What do I mean by that,
there are a lot of you always trying to invest
into dedicated founder,
but when this founder is very dedicated
and has no flexibility
and is just going straight, straight ahead,
hitting the mountain head to head
sometimes it doesn't work.
And you need to be flexible enough
to accept this and to not go
and just like be completely broken,
but reinvent yourself.
So, those companies
that succeed to reinvent themselves,
those are the good ones.
The ones that kind of hit the wall
and can't reinvent themselves,
those are the ones that kind of die off.
So, that's the main difference.
I would say the good founder has to have
has to have a lot of dedication
and enough of flexibility
to be able to reinvent itself.
This is the for me, this is the difference
between the companies that are successful
and companies that are going nowhere.
But how do you measure flexibility
when you do, let's say,
three week due diligence process,
you meet the entrepreneur four or five times.
How do you measure
an entrepreneurs ability to be flexible?
Because you're also you're funding
in the early stages,
when you're essentially investing in the person.
How do you measure flexibility?
That's actually a great question.
This is something that it took me at least time
to learn and to figure it out.
In real life, what matters when you go
and you meet a person
and when you actually have
a more deeper conversations,
when it's not just a pitch
and they just like pitching you the company,
we're saying, "What do you think?"
And so, like,
when you actually have a deeper,
deeper conversations
and you meet the whole team
and you see the dynamics between them,
you see how they actually interact.
Because usually, usually people
have a very different opinions.
In early stage, if there is a strong team,
there are always strong opinions.
And there are two ways of kind of
those companies to work.
Sometimes it's just a clash of opinions.
And in the end, someone just says,
"You know what? Okay.
I'm the CEO, so I'll decide."
And things are not heard much.
Another thing is that you can see that
it's a very slight different.
The CEO isn't the final decision maker,
because that's what you want from a CEO.
But you see that
he might be completely disagree
with the other opinion,
but he'll still consider it.
So, there's a slight difference.
If you feel that there is,
I think this is a good sign,
it's not a guarantee,
but it's a good sign that
there is enough flexibility in this person.
And just something you learn
from those two, three weeks
of having conversations.
I have, for example,
I have a several occasions where I have
to find kind of pull out the term sheets
when we've already got to the point
when it wasn't the first date or second date,
when I was kind of that we started
our relationship to the next level.
And right before signing the term sheet,
you see that the person has just lost,
his flexibility ended after a third meeting
and now it's like he's completely
or she's completely inflexible.
And that's where I usually pull out,
if that happens.
Right. I think that's really interesting.
And so, how many investments
would you say you've seen
or played around with over your career?
I have a portfolio of twenty five plus companies
that I actually, like my teams and I invested.
The overall, I would say probably over,
over these eight years,
probably several thousand companies.
And honestly, to be honest,
that I actually like dug in deeply,
I would say it's probably
maybe five, 700, I don't know,
a lot of companies those eight years.
So, what part of this cycle
of venture capital
do you enjoy most personally?
So, there's so many different
moving pieces, right?
And anybody who's gone through
a cycle of fundraising knows that
it's like a big roller coaster,
both for the entrepreneur,
but also for the investor
from the deal sourcing
to the diligence to the decision
to then supporting the portfolio company.
It's a whole balogun.
So, which part is your favorite?
So, the favorite part is really
is a some kind of a exit.
You know, that's the favorite part for everyone.
And when everyone is happy
and usually it's after the hard,
like the hard track of difficulties
and all kinds of things happen.
Now, you're asking about like more,
like earlier part there's a joke between VCs.
VCs say that the fun is over
when you actually wire the money.
That's one.
So, the part before that,
the whole getting to know the company,
meeting the entrepreneurs,
getting really into what they are doing,
and being getting to know the entrepreneurs,
I think this is the funnest part.
This is the most enjoyable part.
And specifically, sometimes,
you just click with the founders,
with the entrepreneurs.
So, for me, the people ability
to kind of become a part of their journey
and be helpful to them
and meet their world,
because you're like you meet those
very very exciting people
who are like they've done things,
they are doing things.
They are dreamers,
they're executioners.
And you kind of you get all this energy,
this is the most exciting part.
And also, that's where you decide for yourself
how you can actually be helpful
to the company,
like what you can actually deliver.
A lot of funds,
a lot of VCs say value add and like,
I'll make introductions,
I'll bring you in more and more investor
to help you raise money and so on.
So, that's something that a lot of VCs can do
because everyone comes
with some kind of background.
So, sometimes it's,
it's when you connect to the CEO
and we actually feel
that we can help the CEO
on specific tasks
like the CEO comes to you and says,
"Hey, bro, I need help
with hiring this person."
"I can't fill this position for a while."
"Please help, help."
That's what kind of makes you feel
like you're really part of this company
when you can solve specific issues
and not just be another person
to make introductions.
That makes perfect sense.
So, if you're now looking at
young entrepreneurs
that are starting their journey,
perhaps they've never raised money from VCs,
or they're now, they're reaching new rounds
that they haven't reached before.
So, what advice would you give them
as they're thinking, both in terms of
growing and scaling the company?
And you've seen some companies scale
with the portfolio
or in terms of their communication
with the venture capital partners.
Okay. That's a good question.
I would say, first of all,
it has to be you have to realize
that the raising money is not easy.
It's just not it's not a simple process.
And there will be a lot of discouraging moments
when people will be saying,
you'll get no up to no.
And also you will get
multiple completely contradicting opinions
from smart people.
You go to one smart VC and he tells you,
"Hey, you're doing all these wrong."
"You have to do XYZ."
And you'll go to another person
and he'll tell you completely opposite thing.
So, you have to be able to focus
on what you do and be kind of,
again flexibility.
Listen to the people,
get their feedback just a little bit
but keep your core.
Don't link analogies.
Don't go and change your
what do you do from meeting to meeting.
That's one thing.
How do you balance that?
So, how do you balance
when you're approaching two different VCs,
both very reputable,
but they're giving contradictory ideas
and you're sort of in the middle?
Because the whole power struggle
at that point is
the VC is more knowledgeable.
They're assessing your validity.
And if a VC tells you that
you're doing something wrong,
then you're questioning yourself.
Another VC says you're doing something right
then now you're confused
as to how to approach this.
So, I think, first of all,
the by default, by definition, I wouldn't say
that the VC is more knowledgeable.
or smarter than you.
The VC is another entrepreneur,
hopefully another entrepreneur
who is just in a different stage in his life.
And someone who, a VC
the good VC is looking for
a CEO of the company who is a leader,
who can lead this opportunity.
A VC doesn't want to lead this thing,
like if I would be smart enough,
I would say no to the entrepreneurs.
I'm saying, "Guys, you know,
if I would know this better than you
so, I would probably start this company."
"Why am I investing here?"
"Because I trust you in your judgment."
So, I think that's the point.
You have to be,
there's a very thin border between,
very thin line between being stubborn
and kind of done next to being flexible,
then next is being
completely all over the place.
So, I would say this flexibility,
when you do know what you're doing
and you do believe
in what the way you chose,
but you understand that you probably
do not know all the details
and there are other people
who have experienced
that you have to acknowledge.
So, that's the one that creates
the healthy conversations.
And, you know, sometimes VCs,
great VCs have wrong opinions.
You know, every great VC,
I'm not even so great,
have an anti-portfolio
where they missed a lot of good companies.
So, that's them.
That's always happens.
Right, I think that almost every VC,
that every venture capital partner
that I met in Silicon Valley so far
has this crazy story of how
they passed on Airbnb or Lyft
or one of those great companies
when they were young.
And now and then they're reflecting.
They're thinking,
"Okay, why did we missed them?"
And it's not like the VC knows everything
and that you're able to assess amazingly
the validity of a company, you also miss.
A good friend of mine passed on Airbnb.
Yup, that's the reality.
Definitely.
Exactly.
Now, you have young entrepreneurs
that are looking to meet you, for example,
that are that are raising money,
what kind of advice
just seeing a lot of other companies
would you give them specifically saying
these are the things
that you should be focusing
in the early stages of your company.
Maybe it's to go full throttle on fundraising,
or maybe it's to find some balance,
and how do they look
for the right investors.
What are some things
that you think are really important?
So, you know, I always,
always ask this question myself, as also,
you know, as the entrepreneur,
because I've raised money before
for my companies.
And hopefully if I start other companies,
I will probably raise money again.
So, it's hard to judge
from the position of the VC.
But I think, I'll speak of myself,
when the entrepreneurs come to me
in their early stage, first of all,
I look for the acknowledgement
that they don't know everything.
When people come to me
and they start laying out a three year plan
with like details in this,
I'm like, whoa.
"Guys, you haven't really started yet."
"How they know what's going to happen?"
And my point the answer is,
"We don't really know
but that's what we expect
and that's what we're going to go for."
Right.
The idea is,
I want to see that the entrepreneur
thought through a lot of things really deeply
and they understand the challenges,
the problems and unknowns
that they have in the way.
Right. While keeping in mind
that they don't know everything.
Yeah, because that's exactly.
Because it's very strange to see
an early stage company,
seed company comes to you and says,
"We're have this five pilots in three months,
we're going to close those five clients
and so on."
So now, and so what happens
if you guys don't close?
So, I would say that they'd be realistic.
And being visionary,
but at the same time being realistic.
It's a lot of contradictory things.
It's something that kind of
specifically speaks to me.
Right.
I think to me, it sounds like
you're looking for the visionary
and having the humility of knowing that
while you might be a visionary,
it's quite possible being visionary
doesn't contradict being open minded.
Understanding that the vision can change
according to the circumstances.
Right now you have the information X,
already have X plus Y,
that's a new world right there.
Now you have to be visionary again
and reinvent yourself.
I know very important,
the crucial thing is just know your stuff.
Meaning, when you speak to a CEO
that gives you the product, it usually happens
when the CEO is a product person,
not really a business person.
You have a really deep conversation
about the product and what it does
and what we'll do,
envision how it's going to change the world
that can change everything.
I want to get to the card numbers and just,
okay, so let's talk about
how we can make it happen.
That's when it starts, you know,
Oh, this is like my other co-founder did hat,
and I don't know this number.
You don't have to know everything,
but you have to be able to operate
your excels and your financials,
like the way you're actually
that you have it in your mind.
So that's what gives you confidence
about the CEO and about the co-founders.
I think there is a growing misconception,
almost that people believe that
they're coming in for an interview.
Like the VC is going to ask them
as if it's on Shark Tank,
they're going to ask them for these numbers
and they're testing their memory
to see whether they're serious or not.
But that's not how it works.
When you ask somebody for a number
or like a forecast for something,
it's not to test
whether they memorize the number.
It's an actual question.
And if they give off a vibe
that they're not owning the information,
that they don't understand the process of,
that maybe the other co-founder has done.
It's fine that they did the work.
But you need to understand the process
and be able to take ownership of it
if you're representing the company.
And so, I think that
that is an interesting element.
Yeah, that's a great element.
And it's just important because
exactly what you said you want to see,
like you want to understand this number.
Like, here's a VC, as a person
who's done business yourself,
you understand that
there is a very high probability
that those numbers aren't correct
for all different reasons.
That you want to understand
that the person understands
how this actually forms,
how that comes to life.
And if the person understands that,
then you can say,
okay, this guy actually knows what to expect
and he'll be able to react.
Right.
So, that's what you want to do.
Exactly.
I love it.
Levy, this has been so much fun.
Unfortunately we have to end.
20 minutes are over.
But I have the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
I've been waiting for that.
So, first of all,
thanks for giving me a heads up for this.
I've been actually able to think about it.
So, I would say that
I think when I think about myself,
I'm thinking about curiosity.
I happen to be a very I would say,
what's the word, the English,
I don't like following the herd,
I don't like following the crowd.
Yeah.
And the last thing I would say,
I'm probably pretty entrepreneurial,
which sometimes actually
is a negative to be a VC
because you get too passionate about things.
And instead of cold mind outside,
you become one of the hard brained inside.
Levy, thank you so much.
This is really great.
Toda raba. Stay safe and stay healthy
until this craziness is over.
Yeah. Let us all come out of it
better and stronger
and healthier people.
May God help us all.
Just to stay safe through all this.
Thanks. Thanks for having me.